[Music]
they come with their babies the young
old and ill all on a mission to find
food medicine or work these were ones
with documents they can at least cross
legally Margaretta paid a smuggler to
get her across like so many Venezuelans
she couldn't afford a passport she's
left her four children in Caracas with
her mother while she tries to find local
Colombia then as well as economic crisis
is splitting families apart
[Music]
Marjorie too paid a smuggler the
equivalent of more than two years salary
to cross without papers she says her
baby got sick along the way she and her
four children spent 10 days traveling
here now none of them can afford to go
any further and they've been living on a
pavement here for the past eight days
border guards are on standby in case of
trouble xenophobic outbursts have flared
on a number of Venezuela's borders as
her citizens flee the economic meltdown
in their tens of thousands those unable
to leave permanently fill up cases and
take back basics like nappies and food
supplies there are no supplies he says
an inflation in Colombia's almost
nothing in Kakuta it's led to a mini
business boom here traders by the
Venezuelan women's hair although they
don't want to be identified by us just
today she tells us that's 1.2 million
pesos around $600 and more than a
month's salary
many of the Venezuelans just head
straight here to the health services
that have been set up here on the border
a lot of these people just haven't seen
medical facilities or hand access to
them in months and this is the first
chance for them to get help
many arrived malnourished bran David's
underweight and not as tall as he should
be for nearly three years old his mother
says she's been forced to cross over
because there's next to nothing
there are no doctors there are no
medicines it's very hard she says
Venezuela's problems are not going away
fast and their neighbors are feeling the
strain more and more Alex Crawford Sky
News on the Venezuelan Colombian border